all right so Warner Brothers has
released a picture of Henry Cavill in
the Superman outfit and Anne Hathaway in
the Catwoman outfit and although I
talked about both on my website WWE an
same let's plug yea to costume
revelations that's video worthy right
there
first of all Henry Cavill as Superman
this picture is really cool look at him
right there just BAM I'm a badass he
really doesn't make a badass - he's just
striking a pose he's like yeah I don't
mess with Metropolis this is what
happens that bolts your face now this
guy in the outfit they both look pretty
legit it looks exactly how a Superman
outfit should look I mean there's no
surprises here that cape looks a little
long though I mean honestly try running
in that thing what happened it's like
the spawn cave but this picture gave me
all sorts of faith in the world and
Henry Cavill as Superman like I said I
don't know much about the guy other than
he was the Count of Monte Cristo's kid
no Superman curl in the hair though
which is sad is it necessary know you
can still be Superman and not have the
curl for the first time whichever in
life I know someone else is gonna be
like no actually he didn't have the curl
and stop whatever but his hair is all
slicked back I don't know if he's gonna
save my life or snuff me in the desert
because I counted cards at the blackjack
tables in either case he does look like
a badass mom a badass if for nothing
else this picture could be like a bank
ad for free checking checking fees
kal-el does not approve and now on to
Anne Hathaway as Catwoman there is not a
human being on earth who isn't torn on
this picture because for the most part
she looks like what we would think
Catwoman would look like in a
christopher nolan movie she has the
black outfit that she probably bought
from hot topic or hustler Hollywood or
something figured that then you see her
with these sunglasses and you realize
the one thing missing from this picture
is the key-maker I know the joke was way
too easy but I had to and I personally
am a bit torn on it because does she
look like Catwoman not necessarily she
looked like she could be a cat burglar
yeah is Catwoman a cat burglar yeah so
there that is and if you look at the
comic book Catwoman does have shades and
if you look at the shades they do the
Catwoman ish they got like ridges on the
top I got a little bridge for the nose
look look I have some LEDs so it's like
night vision or its gonna do something
cool I'm sure probably a fancy little
piece of tech that I myself would
probably want what I could rock those
but Catwoman also looks like a cat she
has like the hood with the cat ears and
this one she doesn't have that I mean I
would think the first revealed picture
of Anne Hathaway's Catwoman you'd make
her look like Catwoman so striking a
pose with a whip or something that'd be
sweet does she have a whip I hope she
has the whip not just because I want to
see her with Catwoman zwip but I want to
see her with Catwoman zwip so it makes
me wonder issue Selina Kyle a cat
burglar who by the end of the movie will
be Catwoman and she will have the cat
ears and what
possible could be like Catwoman begins
but called the Dark Knight Rises
but if you look at any of the other
villains in the null and Batman's people
griped about them - like scarecrow had a
suit not a scarecrow outfit and actually
with the Joker when the first pictures
of the Joker came out people were like
oh yeah he looks like the Joker but
doesn't look like he feels like the
Joker one movie and one Oscar later they
were wrong like dead wrong I mean after
all that is not Bane's mask like in the
least but I have no problem of that I
don't think I could about Catwoman
not having the ears but I'll hold off
passing up too much judgement until the
trailer comes out I want to see like
video I want to see interaction
interesting things she's on the Batpod
people are speculating like who's she
working with Batman I hope not I hope
their love/hate relationship starts out
as hey so I hope she just jacked it from
him or maybe by the end of the movie
they work together to take out Bane I am
hyped about one thing and this was the
thing that was concerning me I was like
it's Catwoman gonna have long hair cuz
an Anne Hathaway's new movie she cut her
hair and I was scared but yet long hair
and I'm happy so Henry Cavill as
Superman and Anne Hathaway's Catwoman
what do you think of these pictures
comment below let me know and if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
or super mental punch your face like a
bank vault or Snuffy in the desert I'm a
badass